we're just going to bring you these
live and exclusive pictures here from
inside
the presidential palace
what you are looking at right now
is taliban fighters
inside the presidential palace uh this
is these pictures exclusive on al
jazeera
uh
that we've been watching them for a few
moments now milling around the the lush
environs of the presidential palace
we're not sure if they're making an
announcement yet but the the camera has
been trailing those fighters as they
make their way through the halls of the
afghan presidential palace
wandering up through the building uh
decta in its finery of course this after
the afghan president
uh fled
the capital
taliban fighters placing their guns on
the desks sitting behind the desk
of we assume that is the uh desk of the
the afghan president a fairly stunning
turnaround
of events
in kabul you started the day
uh certainly with the the news that the
taliban fighters were surrounding the
city
now they're inside the presidential
palace
you